well black friday deals and online
shopping really go hand in hand
just make sure you're not falling victim
to any cyber criminals
who might want to steal your information
kirsten joyce is on your side tonight
with some important tips
denise we can never share these
reminders enough and especially now when
online shopping is at an all-time high
with the pantemic
so too are the bad guys looking to get
your info
just in the first half of november we
saw an 80 percent
increase in these hacking fishing
campaigns
my levine is a cyber security expert
with checkpoint the company has been
doing research for the past 25 years
on these type of attacks around the
globe and while many big companies get
hacked and
individuals fall victim to it as well
you do have some control
the biggest factor are your credentials
the passwords you choose to use for
certain accounts
and the experts say never share those
credential theft is a huge goal of cyber
attacks
mainly because people reuse their
credentials
often across accounts so if they can get
your credentials for one account
they might have access to multiple
accounts so be very suspicious
of password reset emails also have a
different password for each account and
change them often
use something like password manager also
be wary of two good to be true bargains
which are usually just
phishing attempts to get your
information and finally look for the
lock don't buy something from a website
that does not have that secure sockets
layer encryption installed
look for that s in https that icon of
the locked padlock
it's going to appear to the left of the
ulr no lock
is a major red flag brian